hi everyone eddie wu here it's a real
privilege to be speaking to you as part
of national eos
awareness week eos awareness week is all
about helping our community
understand what eosinophilic disorders
are and appreciate what it's like to
live with them and the struggles that
that can mean
my family is affected by eosinophilic
disorders my son has
eosinophilic esophagitis and so i was
really grateful for the help of
communities
like aussiee which was started by sarah
gray
in response to the fact that there was
so little information out there about
this very
rare set of disorders and so as part of
this week what i want to read to you
is a book that sarah wrote called meet
arabella
it's something which i found enormously
helpful to know that we weren't alone
and to wrap our head around the
particular struggles that our son was
going through
so it's amazingly the 10th anniversary
of this book and you can get a copy of
this at the aussie
website it's really wonderful to get a
better sense
of what the people around us are
experiencing especially when some of the
struggles
can be really invisible and they often
affect us socially
so i'm going to read this book now and i
hope you enjoy
this is meet arabella by sarah gray
arabella is just like every other kid in
her class
except sometimes she gets bubbles in her
throat
and rumbles in her tummy it is not
unusual for arabella to get bubbles in
her throat and rumbles in her tummy
because she has been getting those
feelings for as long
as she can remember
it all started when arabella was a baby
she was just like
every other baby in her play group
except when arabella ate food
it didn't make her feel good it made her
feel
sick sometimes she got a tummy ache
sometimes she had runny poo and
sometimes
she found it hard to swallow her food
arabella's mum and dad did not know what
was making her feel that way
so they took her to the doctor the
doctor did not know what was making
arabella feel that way
either so he said she needed to have
some tests
one of the tests arabella had to have
was a blood test
she tried to be very brave
but still arabella's doctor could not
find what was making her feel that way
he suggested that she go to a special
doctor called a pediatrician
the pediatrician thought about all the
things arabella was feeling
and said that she needed to see a
stomach doctor called
a gastroenterologist the
gastroenterologist
said she wanted to have a look inside
arabella's throat and tummy
with a special camera called an
endoscope
she hoped that the endoscopy would help
her to find out what was making arabella
feel that way
arabella was a little scared when she
went to the hospital for the endoscopy
but a very nice doctor called an
anesthetist helped her to go to sleep
when she woke up the endoscopy was all
over and she only had
a little sore throat
they finally knew what was making
arabella feel that way
the gastroenterologist said that she had
something called
isinophilic esophagitis her mum and dad
said
eozono what
so she explained that meant arabella had
too many white blood cells called
easenophiles in her throat and that
these blood cells
didn't like it when she ate certain
foods
she said most people called it eoa for
sure
now that all the doctors knew that
arabella had eoe
they could try to make her feel better
the doctor said arabella would feel
better if she drank a special type of
drink
called an elemental formula
the director explained that if arabella
did not drink enough of the formula to
grow big and strong
then she may need to have it through a
tube
the tube could be put down her nose into
her tummy
or straight into her tummy by something
called a peg
or a button the doctor
also wanted arabella to visit another
special doctor
called an allergist to help find out
what foods she may be allergic to
arabella was a little nervous when she
met the allergist for the allergy
testing
but it didn't hurt much at all and they
found out she was allergic to egg
dairy soy corn wheat
and fish so arabella
stopped eating those foods and she went
to talk to a dietitian
about the best foods for her to eat
that was five years ago and arabella
doesn't remember much of it very well
now she is seven years old every day
before school
she has to have her medicines and then
pack her special formula
to give her energy at school
sometimes her classmates help to remind
her to drink her formula
they know why she needs it because the
teacher explained to the kids about her
allergies
and her eozonophilic esophagitis
they all said iozino what
arabella is the only kid in her school
that has eoe
and sometimes this makes her feel
different
but one day arabella met a boy named
henry
who had eoe 2 and it made her feel good
to know someone
who was just like her do you know
someone
like arabella
and that's the end of the story i hope
you found that a lovely insight into the
world of children
and adults who suffer from easinophilic
disorders
um they can affect the esophagus or
anywhere along the gastrointestinal
tract
and one of the most challenging things
about it is that because it affects the
food that you eat and it's often
misunderstood it really has an impact on
every social interaction
you have so many times that we gather to
celebrate or be
joyful and enjoy each other's company is
when we eat
so sensitivity and understanding to that
is super important
and that's why i'm so grateful for this
story
i hope you have a great national eos
awareness week there are lots of other
fantastic videos
being released and i hope they all
enrich your understanding of these
conditions
and what we can do to help people who
suffer from them